anyone who's ever used a Mercedes
Sprinter for a move knows just how much
furniture can fit inside but this heimer
car isn't your standard multipurpose
Sprinter it's a fully equipped camper
van that was developed by heimer and
Mercedes designed to meet your every
need while on holiday our car tester
Michelle Assenmacher is trying out the
Grand Canyon s it's based on the
Mercedes Sprinter and has tailor-made
furniture from heimer
the vehicle is five point nine three
meters long and seats four people the
seats can be arranged around a table
there's plenty of storage space thanks
to the many cupboards but the vehicle
never seems cramped due to a
well-designed interior in all open
amenities we all tend to take lots of
stuff on holiday but there are enough
drawers for storing everything but to
ensure nothing goes flying around the
van while driving the drawers come with
special catches to lock them all you
need to do is push the buttons on Shawn
come it's a posse on the Grand Canyon s
has also fitted with a small kitchen so
no one needs to go hungry there's a hob
with two rings under this cover and a
small sink
and there's a tall fridge besides the
kitchen unit offering plenty of space
console and of course no campervan is
complete without a toilet and a shower
they're located here the basin is fitted
onto the side wall and can be folded
away to save space it comes with a
pull-out water tap that can also be used
for showering the show points out
there's a shower curtain to prevent
everything from getting wet what more
could you ask for
the Grand Canyon s also comes with comfy
mattresses unlike many other camper vans
where seating areas double up as beds
Darren can see the Grand Canyon has is
cleverly laid out Michele demonstrates
another space-saving feature
the Vans rear can be quickly transformed
into a cozy bed for two and in
summertime you can look through the rear
doors onto the sea while you're nodding
off
Conestoga Alto Samia blinking on table
and fluffy
Michelle likes the Grand Canyon s a lot
she finds regular campervans just too
big for people her age but this smaller
van is really to her liking tough the
non language market and so there's a
campervan for every taste smaller and
more agile vans like this one are
beginning to match up to the bigger ones
in terms of features and they weigh less
so in many countries no special driver's
license is necessary